.
TA.
APICKET LIN T AYING TU >>
ISF DISCUSSION AROUND
E
RDING
ELLIGEA.I. COU TL
STREAMING SERVICES.
Y GARBS. IS WHERI BRING IN
HAANR NETFLIX AND FOHULU.
OU WERE
INNOKED A ISWAS JUST RECEIVING
THATEHE WILL GET CHECKSRO
HE DID IH
MORE THARES FORBIG CORPORATNSILT
T
I UNDERSTAEASUCHCHOR
E  SORT
IR AAKING Y.
>> TELL ME A LITTLE BIT T
>>BEENME TDO EXTRA WORK O
T OF WAITING IN
AND I K OFHESSHROUGH
SED OFFSIDUALS.
BILLS.AT HAV
RKSHOWS WITH HAVE TOAVE
JUETWHILE WORKG
E MONE JT NOT I>>N E ON THE
>> ABSOLUTELY 100%
>>CHTEITORY.EGARDING A
BIG
THREAT RIGHT NOWCATAITKNO S ICH.
THORATION CAN PAYOA DA
FOUR MN.
TODAY?
ERFES DAY HISTRIKEWHICU
AND I'VEN T T  EITERAND PET ENEG
ARE HEARINFR STU
E YOU NT>> MEAN, I JUST ATE YOU
CAEPLACE IT.
WHAT DO YOU  DOING,
S TELLH
BE REPLACED ANRYOU CAN'T DO T
ACTRESS OTE REAC>> THANK, WE ARE
JANITORS,HAS GOING ON FOR MORES
AKP ARTIST
ARE AT A STANDSTILL. P
I  THEKE'OB
STST WHO SAID  TT
MUCH MORE,BRL
E ITIN UK,NDZEALAND.
AND THAT GLOBAL IMPACTS CO
BE AT LEAST FOUR BILLION
UNITE FROM WH YOU WERE SANG THE
A E PREPARED
STRIKT
A  LL.A..
THANK YOU T
OM AD A PROPOSAL FROM
THE STUDRTIFIC
LLIGENCE WOULD BE USED IN
ELEVISION SHOWS.
A L T GRODBAGRA PUZZLE PROPOSEE
ABLE TO BE SCANNED ANDAY FOR
S PAY, AND THAT THEIR
COMPANS SHOULDWNHAHED SHOUUSE IT
THREETERNITY.
ANPREC
NO CONSENT ANDEN.
LDTODAU IN
ON
THE USE OF COULVEIT IE ANALSPET
OF HISTORI. IN
PERTINENT DEBATES IE.I HAVEING
THIS IS GOING TO INTENSELY POLF
ST0 YEARS FROMNTERNET
SMARTPHONE, IT G DITAL
ECOSYSTEMS AND DIGITAL
A.U NCLEPARTICULAR
VOTI, BECAUSE FOFIRST TI YE  A G
UN TS ARTIAL
AL CBIIT IDISRUP
LLTO BEE EFFECTOFTOF
AND THE HICAQUGE
S GETTING OUTHAT S IS GETTING AO
WHAT EXTENT IS
WENT OR WON IS THATT NG TAND EM
LVED REALLY IS THE
IN OTHIS BEING VREE FIRST
ME ANG TD THE
S LAID OUT.
ESW FAR THIS GOES,
ARDEPEND POWER
LIES.
COME OUT IN SUPPORT OF LESSE
IFS OVERME,
ESTION IS HOW MUCH
RAHAPRTHUSE OF I
LY BEING UINDUSTRY.
I DON'T THINKRE
N ENTENMI THINK A FUNDAMTA OF K
ACS AN
INS  MHOWE SHARE SOME HEE
ABDANCE  H T
WITH
.
COMPENSATED FOR THAT.EY A B
CAUSE THAT SHOULD  TP. DWAS RENE
TTHWHHAPPENING WITH BIGLYAR FON
INTLTHINK IT W W
HER.
OMPENSAT FTHAT.
BACK RRS CNSF YOU ARE ADVISING S
TO THEM?HAT TO, WH PROTECTIONS U
GOET THEE.
WWEY EVENTS
THER IN JAF THE CONVERSATION
WATHTHING THAT THEY WE
AT BUT HE DID NOT THINK
LDL ANTORS ARIBEEPX, MONTHS JUSS
TONENTIRELY DIFFERENT.IT IRY IO
ITCHED VERCL HER SEC AIG
LABORE SAID, WE WE ARE JUST EAH
T INDU. NO
ALSHE SAID THAT THISS A
HISTORIC MT D INDE I
ECH HAHISTORCEBETHE
AND TSHE I
PART UBC
FAR BEYOND, I THIN T
NMENT SECTOR IWANT TOWG REAL LEG
THEY DID NOT USE ANY GRAPHIC AN.
OFF HA FOR Y IT IS.
IT WAS KIND OF AN ARTISTIC
TAKE.
BEUSILLE REPLACE
BUT IT ALSO  IWEE ALKING ABOUTA?
D THATUSA
OTECTION?
TERRITORCE
LIGH
CREALICREATIVE WNTADCE THEEAOF E
E CREATORSNEL N THCAUSE THPAISOH